four straight losses all fences gonna
struggle this team right now especially
at home this team right here Ellis
brother they've been struggling mightily
this year they have a chemistry problem
but it is not in a position of strength
right now
Hyannis fast way here the women make no
mistake about it to get the opportunity
to get a young bars getting that guy
like Russell who does have a lot of
talent you able to start over you don't
really get that opportunity in this
league a lot what they're gonna try to
do is build their culture from the
bottom up
the Brooklyn Nets Harris Laverne Babb a
high level of confidence in myself that
I'm ready to go I know it's a journey I
mean you know it's a blessing to be here
and I'm very happy to have this
opportunity for sure you know it's about
development trying to build a winning
culture you know you can always use guys
that can shoot and you know that's what
I do that's why I'm here the Brooklyn
Nets they built this from the
I built a team basically built an
infrastructure that allowed it to get
here their spirit team also in the
Eastern Conference young they got some
pieces that's the cellar allowing
different young guys playing together
it's growing together it's figuring it
out as a group DeAngelo Russell you had
obviously controversy in LA immaturity
in LA ineffectiveness in LA now DeAngelo
Russell is an all-star Aeneas led a team
to the playoffs the guy that they traded
for that no one really thought well how
good the players became an all-star when
you got the Admiral Russell who did not
think that he would be on quarters
of a franchise he has been brilliant you
know it's gonna be the conversation for
most improved player in this league you
can see now his true talent starting to
emerge definitely got a chip on my
shoulder
I always try to play like that with
civil my soda or something approve
Brooklyn has been the best place for him
but now we're seeing what the best
version of the entity Russell is
we all understand you know what it's
like to kind of be an outcast or be cast
aside with always having similar stories
like that it kind of creates a bond what
they've done is instituted a culture
change this is something you can see
going on for years to come
we're we're brothers and we knew what it
was going to take teams counted us out
people counted us out
Jenny Atkinson instilled assert fight
their mistress coach Atkinson seem like
they've really tried to build a culture
there where everybody understands that
did want to be bigger than the
individual the NBA playoffs once again
guys on the roster who have a chip on
their shoulder trust this is no longer a
feel-good story now there are
expectations
[Music]